Assassin… Assassin… Brigand…. Voleur…
Encore assassin…
Alors elles sont oufs ces images parce que
c’est des vraies des photos de criminels
qui datent de 1897. Elles ont été prises
par Cesare Lombroso, un des tout premiers
criminologues. Et faut savoir qu’à l’époque
la criminologie c'était un peu trash parce
qu’on pensait que les criminels c’étaient
des humains mais un peu sous-évolués et
on les étudiait comme si c’était une autre
espèce animale quoi… Francis Galton, un
autre chercheur de l'époque, lui il faisait
des “portraits composites”. Alors il mélangeait
des photos de criminels pour faire ressortir
le visage moyen du criminel de base. Donc
ça par exemple c’est le visage moyen d’un
meurtrier obtenu en mélangeant les visages
de 8 meurtriers différents. Et ça le visage
moyen d’un voleur. Donc c’est vachement
pratique, disent-ils à l’époque, parce
que tous les gens qui ressemblent à peu près
à ça on peut les emprisonner tout de suite
même s’ils ont rien fait, parce qu’ils
portent sur leur visage la signature biologique
du crime. Alors évidemment c’est pas comme
ça que ça marche, hein, sinon y'a longtemps
qu’on aurait emprisonné disons… Philippe
Etchebest et Franck Ribéry quoi…. En même
temps...
Alors cette approche qui dérive de la phrénologie
elle a complètement disparue heureusement,
mais l’idée de pouvoir anticiper les futurs
crimes a ressurgi récemment grâce à une
branche de la fouloscopie qui s'intéresse
au comportement collectif des criminels. Alors
je vais vous expliquer tout ça, dans cette
vidéo on va analyser ensemble tous les crimes
qui ont été commis à Chicago, on va faire
des simulations numériques avec mon invité
surprise, et on va se pencher sur les réseaux
de criminels à Los Angeles. Allez c’est
parti, c’est l’épisode #11 de Fouloscopie.
Dans minority Report, le film de Steven Spielberg,
ce sont des créatures, les précogs, qui
ont des visions des crimes qui vont se produire
dans le future et Tom Cruise est chargé d’interpeller
les futurs criminels avant qu’ils ne passent
à l’action.
Alors non, prédire le crime avec des visions,
c’est pas possible... Là y'a des images
sur le monde, par exemple. Il va faire beau.
Non c’est vraiment pas possible. Par contre
on peut développer des modèles mathématiques
qui sont capables d’estimer le risque qu’un
crime se produise à un certain endroit dans
un future proche. Si vous voulez c’est comme
une sorte de bulletin météo mais pour les
activités criminels, quoi… Tiens d’ailleurs
ça me donne une idée ça...
Bonsoir à tous, le week-end s’annonce mouvementé
avec un taux d’agression très élevé pendant
toute la matinée. Les homicides seront supérieurs
aux normales saisonnières avec notamment
un braquage qui va mal tourner dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais.
Le harcèlement de rue sera toujours très
présent sur l’ensemble du territoire. Je
vous souhaite à tous, une excellente journée.
Bon allez on arrête les blagues, je vais
vous expliquer comment ça marche et pour
ça il me faudrait des données à analyser.
Alors je vais tout de suite regarder sur Google
si je peux trouver un genre d’archives de
criminologie… ça a l’air pas mal, ça…
Alors ici j’ai les données de la Chicago
Police Department. J’ai l’impression d'être
dans une série américaine. Alors on va télécharger
ça pour l’année 2018… C’est ouf yen
a vraiment un paquet... Bienvenue à Chicago…
Bon je vais zoomer sur un petit quartier de
la ville, sinon ça va prendre trop de temps.
Voilà ici autour de Irving Park.. Et on va
regarder tout de suite à quoi ressemble ces
données…
Donc chaque point rouge c’est un crime...
et quand on voit ça on se dit que franchement
c’est impossible de prédire quoi que ce
soit...
Eh bien en fait si. Je vais vous montrer que
si on se penche sur le comportement des criminels
eh bien on peut anticiper chaque jour une
partie des crimes qui vont avoir lieu le jour
suivant. Alors ce sont les travaux d’une
femme qui est devenue en quelques mois la
pire ennemie des gangsters de Chicago… Non
ce n'est pas Dana Scully, ce n'est pas non
plus Debra Morgan, c’est la mathématicienne
Andrea Bertozzi.
Andrea Bertozzi elle a réussi à anticiper
probablement des milliers de crimes grâce
à un seul outil : cette équation.
En fait l’inspiration géniale de Bertozzi,
c’est qu’elle a repris la même équation
qui permet aux sismologues de décrire les
tremblements de terre. Le truc avec le tremblement
de terre, c’est qu’ils ne se produisent
pas n’importe où n’importe quand. La
très grande majorité des tremblements de
terre sont causés... par un précédent tremblement
de terre, on appelle ça des répliques.
Eh bien pour le crime c’est la même chose
: la majorités des crimes sont en fait des
sortes de “répliques” de crimes précédents.
En fait ce qui se passe, c’est que si vous
avez par exemple un cambriolage qui se produit
ici à un moment donné, eh bien dans les
jours qui suivent le risque d’un nouveau
cambriolage autour de ce même lieu sera très
important. Et ce risque s’estompe progressivement
avec le temps.
C’est l’idée que le crime appelle le
crime. Et effectivement c’est une tendance
qu’on retrouve très facilement dans nos
données de Chicago. Ici vous avez par exemple
la fréquence de cambriolages dans les jours
qui suivent un premier cambriolage dans le
même quartier. Et pour comparaison, ça c’est
la même courbe mais cette fois pour les répliques
sismique après un tremblement de terre.
En fait les criminels, il se comporte un peu
comme dans cette simulation que je vous avais
montré dans une précédente vidéo : La
plupart d’entre eux sont des suiveurs qui
vont reproduire ce que les autres ont fait
précédemment. Et on retrouve les mêmes
tendances pour les vols, les coups de feu,
le traffic de drogue et même les violences
conjugales – avec des échelles de temps
un peu différentes à chaque fois.
Alors la bonne nouvelle c’est que ça, eh
bien ça rend les comportements criminels
relativement prévisibles à court-terme.
Si je reprends mes données de Chicago, eh
bien maintenant je peux tracer chaque jour
une carte de risque criminel pour le lendemain.
Il me suffit pour ça d’ajouter l’équation
de Bertozzi dans mon programme… Voilà on
va mettre les paramètres qui sont proposés
dans la publi... OK, voilà donc ce que vous
voyez maintenant à l’écran ce n’est
pas le crime enregistré chaque jour, mais
les zones de crime prédits pour le lendemain.
Alors j’ai pas fait l’analyse statistique
complète parce que ça prendrait trop de
temps quand même, mais d’après les auteurs
la méthode est très efficace.
Ce qui est hallucinant avec cette découverte
c’est la vitesse avec laquelle elle s’est
transformée en application. Quelques mois
après la publication, la police de Santa
Cruz contact un des auteurs Jeffrey Brantingham
pour lui proposer de faire un test grandeur
nature sur le terrain. Les résultats sont
bons, le programme s’étend à d’autres
villes américaines, et Jeffrey Brantingham
créer le logiciel PredPol qu’il vend aux
communes américaines pour quelque dizaines
de milliers de dollars…
– Eh tu veux pas le vendre toi ton programme
là ?
– Quoi ?
– Tu veux pas le vendre ton truc là au
lieu de glander sur Youtube.
– Celui-là ?
Alors ce logiciel predPol, il fonctionne exactement
comme je vous ai montré…
– Yo les potes, comment ça va !
– … salut Cyrus...
– Et dis donc j’étais en train de t’écouter
là... c’est pas un peu Black Mirror ton
truc là ?
– Non c’est pas Black Mirror là, c’est
juste un petit modèle qui peut prédire les
futurs crimes.
– quoi, qu’est ce qui ya ?
– Ben c’est raciste.
– Quoi ?
CN – C’est raciste. Les machines, l’intelligence
artificielle, robocop… tout ça, c’est
raciste c’est bien connu. Tout le monde
le sais. Même ma daronne elle sait que c'est
raciste.
– Non non attends, c’est plutôt le contraire
en fait. Le programme il va avoir tendance
à corriger les biais humains qui existent
déjà chez les policiers... Si tu veux on
fait des simulations tu vas voir c’est clean.
– Hyper chaud ! En plus j'adore quand tu
fais des simulations ! Je suis chaud vas-y
!
– Ok mais après tu me laisse finir la vidéo…
– Promis !
– Allez on lance Matlab.
Alors regarde on va simuler un monde imaginaire
avec des gens qui ont, disons, la peau bleue
et des gens qui ont la peau verte. Et ces
gens ils vivent dans des quartiers différents.
Ça c’est le quartier majoritairement bleu
et ça c’est le quartier majoritairement
vert. Le taux de criminalité, c’est le
même dans les deux quartiers et donc on peut
simuler, jour après jour, les crimes qui
se produisent dans cette ville. Voilà. Ici
chaque point rouge, c’est un crime.
Alors maintenant on va mettre des policiers.
Et on va dire qu’à la base les policiers
ils sont pas complètement neutres, il vont
un petit peu plus souvent patrouiller chez
les bleus que chez les verts. On va dire 55
45. Alors les bleus ils se sentent un peu
discriminés, forcément. Et là je vais simuler
l’algorithme de Predpol qui va envoyer les
policiers là où le risque est le plus important
sans tenir compte de la couleur de peau. Et
je te pari que ce petit biais il va disparaître
et qu’on va revenir à 50/50.
Attention regarde bien ce qui va se passer.
Boum, maintenant !
Euuuh… attend qu’est ce qui se passe là
?
– Et voilà , ils sont racistes…
– Non attends ils sont pas racistes, c’est
un programme informatique. Il doit y avoir
un bug...
– Non non, c’est du racisme anti-bleus…
– Hmmm...Ouai en fait t’as raison: y’a
un problème. Au lieu de corriger le biais,
l’algorithme de Predpol l’a amplifié.
Regarde je t’explique. Le truc c’est qu’on
a une sorte de cercle vicieux qui s’est
mis en place. Plus on envoi des policiers
dans un quartier, plus les chances de détecter
des crimes dans ce quartier seront importantes.
Du coup comme il y a un tout petit peu plus
de policiers chez les bleus au début, le
programme enregistrer plus de crimes chez
les bleus alors qu’en fait c’est juste
qu’ils ont été un peu plus observé que
les verts. On appelle ça un biais d’échantillonnage.
Du coup on envoi encore plus de policiers
chez les bleus et ça amplifie le biais et
ainsi de suite… Et dans la vraie vie, vous
l’avez compris, ceux qui sont victimes de
cette discrimination ils ont pas la peau bleue,
mais plutôt la peau foncée...
– Okay et une fois qu’on a compris ça
on fait quoi ?
– Ben Jeffrey Brantingham il s’est quand
même bien fait incendier dans les médias
à cause de ça. Et lui il propose d’ajouter
un contre-biais dans le programme pour forcer
une affectation des policiers proportionnelle
à la taille de la population. Donc s’il
y a 50% de bleu et 50% de vert eh bien on
force la moitié des policiers chez les bleus
et l’autre moitié chez les verts. Sauf
que si on fait ça, on réduit d’environ
10% le nombre de crime correctement prédit,
parce que des fois on envoi des policiers
là où le risque était moins important.
Du coup le programme est moins efficace. Alors
est-ce qu’il vaut mieux une police efficace
ou une police juste…. Eh bien je vous propose
d'écouter tout de suite Jeffrey Brantingham
qui s'exprime sur ce sujet.
Eh bien en tout cas je vous laisse vous faire
votre propre avis sur cette question, et je
remercie Cyrus. Allez voir sa chaîne ce mec
c’est un vrai cyborg...
Alors je vais vous montrer une autre découverte
importante mais pour ça il faut d’abord
que je vous parle des Krazy ass mexicans.
Les crazy ass mexicans c’est un gang de
la banlieue Est de Los Angeles dont l’activité
criminelle a été étudiée en détail en
2001. Les chercheurs ont référencés toutes
les fusillades entre ce gangs et les gangs
voisins, comme par exemple les White Fences,
les 18th ou encore les Cuatro Flats, ainsi
que les territoires qu’ils occupent dans
la ville.
Alors pour bien vous expliquer cette découverte,
je vais vous représenter ça sous forme d’un
réseau de rivalités entre les gangs. Alors
ce point au milieu c’est les Krazy Ass Mexicans
et à chaque fois qu’il y a une rivalité
connue avec un autre gang, par exemple avec
les white fence, je trace une ligne entre
les deux. Et comme j’ai toutes les données
dans la publi, eh bien je vais faire ça pour
toutes le rivalités connues. Voilà, et je
vais mettre la taille et la couleur des points
proportionnelles au nombre d'agressions que
le gang a commit.
Le truc c’est que les autres gangs c’est
pas non plus des enfants de coeurs et eux
aussi ils se tirent dessus régulièrement.
Par exemple les Quatro Flats ils se sont aussi
embrouillé avec les White Fence, et avec
les hazards, et ainsi de suite. Et en fait
des gangs dans cette banlieue, yen a pas seulement
douze, yen a une bonne trentaine et je peux
donc compléter ce réseau pour avoir maintenant
toutes les rivalités entre tous les gangs
de Los Angeles Est.
Alors cette représentation en réseau, ça
a permit aux chercheurs de découvrir quelque
chose d’important. Si on regarde à quelle
date se sont produites les attaques disons
entre les Quatro Flats et les White Fence,
on obtient ce graphique… Alors ce sont de
vraies données qui ont été collectées
sur une période de 3 ans et ce qu’on voit
c’est que c’est clairement pas aléatoire,
on a des périodes où les attaques se répètent
rapidement, entrecoupées de périodes de
calme. Et en fait ça c’est exactement comme
pour les cambriolages ou pour les tremblements
de terre. Dès qu’une première attaque
a lieu entre deux gangs, le risque d’une
suivante immédiatement après va augmenter.
On est dans une logique d’escalade de la
violence.
Eh bien la première découverte fascinante
qui a été faite grâce à ce réseau, c’est
que ce risque d’agression il se propage
de proche en proche. Donc si il y a une attaque
par exemple entre les Quatro Flats et les
White Fence, ça augmente aussi le risque
pour qu’il y ait dans les jours qui suivent
une attaque entre tous gangs voisins, par
exemple entre les Quatro Flats et les Hazards,
qui pourrait elle-même entraîner une attaque
des Krazy ass Mexicans, et ainsi de suite.
C’est comme si on avait une forme de contagion
des fusillades. Et c’est ça l’idée centrale
qui va être généralisée à tous les crimes
par le sociologue Andrew Papachristos.
Papachristos il se dit eh bien si ça se trouve
cette logique de contagion ça ne s’applique
pas juste aux gangs mais à tout le monde.
Il est donc parti récupérer les archives
de la police et il a retracé le réseau d’interaction
de 170 mille criminels. Regardez-moi cette
beauté. Ici chaque point est un criminels
et deux criminels sont connectés s’ils
se connaissent. Et dans ce réseau on peut
mettre en évidence des cascades de propagation
d’attaque par arme à feu. Dans cet exemple
une première personne se fait tirer dessus,
puis quelques jours plus tard, c’est au
tour d’un de ses amis, qui entraîne deux
nouvelles attaques parmi ses amis et ainsi
de suite. Au final, c’est 34 personne qui
sont victimes indirectement causées par la
première. Et certaines cascade impliquent
encore plus de monde...
La bonne nouvelle avec ça, c’est qu’on
a des outils en épidémiologie pour décrire
et même prédire les phénomènes contagieux.
Du coup Papachristos va faire de l’épidémiologie
criminelle. Par exemple dans ce réseau le
meurtre se propage comme un virus avec un
nombre de reproduction de 0.63, ce qui est
une valeur relativement faible – bien heureusement
sinon ça serait la guerre civile. À chaque
fois qu’une personne est victime d’une
attaque par arme à feu, immédiatement ses
contacts deviennent sujet à risque pendant
une durée de 84 jours.
Enfin le taux de transmission dépend de certain
critères individuels comme l’origine ethnique
ou l’appartenance à un gang.
Alors si on sais à peu près anticiper et
gérer une épidémie, eh bien.. est-ce qu’on
pourrait pas faire la même chose avec le
crime ? C’est la mission que s’est fixé
un médecin virologue reconverti en criminologie
: Gary Slutkin.
Slutkin essaye de prédire qui seront les
prochaines victimes d’attaque par arme à
feu et les met littéralement en quarantaine
pour interrompre la cascade de propagation.
Chaque meurtre évité ne sauve pas une seule
vie, mais toutes celles qui aurait pu être
perdues dans la suite de la chaîne de propagation.
D’après cette conférence, la technique
est extrêmement efficace puisqu’elle aurait
conduit à une baisse de 67% des attaques
dans une banlieue expérimentale de Chicago.
Voilà alors est-ce qu’on est dans Black
Mirror ou est-ce que la fouloscopie va définitivement
en finir avec la criminalité. Eh bien, en
ce qui me concerne le mystère reste encore
entier...